la boll son festival qui met à l'honneur
le cinéma et la musique de film cadre
idéal pour lancer le petit piaf
quelques minutes avant la toute première
projection l'équipe du film fait son
entrée sous le regard protecteur du
réalisateur gérard jugnot et de ses
parents soan n'a qu'une envie je suis un
peu stressé et puis je suis excité
débats devant le film voir combien tu
nul
le petit piaf un long métrage tourné à
la réunion
l'histoire de nelson un écolier de 10
ans qui rêve de devenir chanteur
pour y parvenir le marmaille s'inscrit à
une compétition de chant mais tout ne se
passera pas comme prévu avec son coach
joué par marc lavoine un conte signé
gérard jugnot
ce qui m'intéressait dans le sujet c'est
des thèmes que chien allongé pourquoi
board et la transmission
la passion des têtes quand on est jeune
devoir faire un truc contre contre son
milieu contre ses parents et surtout le
personnage de marquer ce qui est un
personnage que ce soit ont traité un
type y ait un peu à la ramasse qui a
perdu le sens du talent et qui va
retrouver grâce à à à cette transmission
quand le générique de fin sa fiche c'est
une ovation la réunion ses paysages et
sa musique imprègne le film que seul le
public de la baule a pu découvrir en
jouant les gaillards legacy est que ben
voilà pour lisser ces dû réaliser un
rêve j'ai beaucoup aimé j'ai trouvé ça
magnifique
en voyant le film gerry beaucoup de
souvenirs du tournage j'étais très émue
et ça m'a fait plaisir de voir enfin
une famille réunionnaise a fait le
déplacement depuis la vendée voisine
elle aussi est conquise
on est vraiment très fier parce que ce
film du genre
il a représenté notre île avec justement
avec les choses drôles avec l'émotion
moi j'ai pensé
marc lavoine
il ya eu des silences et moi comme maman
j'ai pleuré un petit peu tu voulais pas
lui faire un petit à petit quelque chose
comme ça bah oui surprise pour le public
la séance s'est achevée en chansons un
avant goût du film qui sortira en salles
début 2000 22 nations et qu'on me
regarde le ciel
imaginlab à tous elle